okay well first thanks very much for the
organizers in firt where everyone else
and to me at least the fact of it was a
lot of arguing here meant there was a
lot to argue about it was interesting to
argue about IMS some of the crucial the
crucial part okay so I just wanted to
make a few comments I don't come very
profound but I think they're all things
that are worth the comment to the mate
worth making and this is from the
perspective of a condensed matter
physicists and penny ones in channels
like explain why and as matter is
irrelevant
magic t'v am adjectives there so I'm
just going to a few comments first about
numbers and general issues some vague
things about evolvability and trying to
type fit of things together maybe I
meant a bit about models and
extrapolation from from those the first
thing is how bigger the the numbers so
the time on earth which is much always
emphasized but anyone talking about
evolution is a very long time even for
bacteria the number generations is
substantially less than 10 to 12 usually
much less that's an upper bound but the
total number of bacteria on earth is
really enormous estimates in the 10 to
the 30th range right which means if you
ask what are the total number of
bacterial cell divisions ever so the
number of experiments bump evolution or
the number of tents assigning something
better whatever that means
that's the product of these which I'm
calling a for convenience and that's
numbers of order M 10 to the 40 and most
of that number comes from the very big
population doesn't come from the time
right if you want to emphasize big
numbers emphasize is the number of
individuals which is to do the size of
the earth if you said okay back to your
boring you're interested in vertebrates
then the total time of generations is
less than 10 to 9 that ballpark but the
number at any given time is bigger than
10 to the 13 and so again the big number
which is the product is dominated by the
total number and it's a it's very large
a means ballpark a burghers number
possibly okay there are all other
numbers and leaving no idea how to even
define them so number of niches which in
a very loose sense is the number of
possible problems to solve and that's
one that's come out various times here
is an extremely important part is it
doesn't try to solve one problem it
solves doesn't try but it ends up
solving one or very many
Mexico started with complexity
environment organisms you know I want to
characterize these by dimensions and
things came up in Carl's look some talk
there you know Fitness is all be
something which
plural the Kurds are multiple time
scales and so on and there's all kinds
of things which come in here which there
are numbers that we know like sizes of
genomes but you know why they're in
sizes they are all the significance of
that with no item with no idea okay
and of course rates are genetic changes
and the process is there which ones
dominate particularly roles of
recombination and gene transfer that
various people have also talked about
okay um so polynomial will not okay so
this is gang of five maybe more than
five I think five I mean we're both
they're talking um so just to avoid
confusing notation so I'm calling K the
something like number of variables
involved it was called little n the
number of mutations needed to cross some
fitness valley or some generic term like
that which is somewhat how complex it is
so if I have a problem if it's non
polynomial if it's hard to solve but it
happens to be the number of attempts
needed goes as e to the K to the
one-third so the Cabaye still goes the e
to the K to one-third so it was not
polynomial but it's not a simple
exponential either then you know if K FC
is one you can get K of ten to the six
on evolution timescales if C is 8 which
if I plugged in a stupid estimate from
what I learned the other day from
factorization then Kaiser water mm today
is what you would call little n yeah
yeah so they get the e to the hundreds I
can I can put in a million here and I
get you the hundred okay if I want to do
if I just plugged in for K to the one
third for for factorization and I needed
a see of eight to fit this to 125
roughly and then the ballpark is okay
you can get a couple thousands okay so
it's very big very big numbers because
the basic number of attempts possible is
extremely large
no no the point is that I really have to
look at the difference I can't just say
something's not polynomial therefore
it's really hard it's hard but what has
a hell of a lot of attempts that
evolution is made right so I'm using
this either the Canadian one third it
comes up in other contexts finding spin
lost ground States and so on and it took
a borderline case and I'll come back to
that the other one is that if it's
polynomial so first is a polynomial and
so they're going this is the k2 some to
some power
they don't move into the question is
does recombination change that pattern
right it's still polynomial but maybe
it's a faster polynomial neither
polynomial with recombination or with
some other processes and that's a really
important one too or does it depend upon
a lot on the selection regime and how
the other processes yeah so that that's
a concrete result the particular context
I've been mentioned a minute or where we
can say how things the pendulum the
parameters and that's really handsome
tonics in various various regimes and I
think those kind of results are very
instructive sometimes when applying
directly to experiments and that's of
course at least something one can say
concretely in make contact with the real
world so I think a very important point
would you told them Balian by do you
know what you won't be surprised by and
one of the big about it to me at least
of trying to show which things may seem
difficult but in fact our polynomial
evolvable means okay those want to be
getting no we're not to be surprised by
those we can try to pin things down on
the ones that maybe we do have to be
surprised by stills and maybe those are
extremely rare maybe evolution to get to
where heaven Earth from the diversity
and so on needs rare events with
probability 10 to the minus 35 or 10 to
the minus 40 okay well maybe it doesn't
we don't know we don't know which things
really need rare events which ones don't
and this is a question to the size of
the earth matter but if I don't need
such rare events and I make an earth ten
to the six times smaller but with some
of the diversity of environments in it
then will evolution be different or will
it be roughly the same right into that
this question of whether the big numbers
really matter
retire right what do you do for an
atmosphere no I can I can come I can
constrain keep all the geophysical
parameters the same right but just
change the just change the size okay
none practice I come in on bill dealing
with existing physical laws I probably
can we there's so many possible planets
around we've discovering them I don't do
it at mascara this is something you know
this is Godzilla or some other gods role
okay
so so one of the things which isn't also
an important observation and this is
true on short timescales and long
timescales is it rare events are
important one can learn something about
asking which of the rarest events
there's still ones that can occur in the
time scale and population size to the
experiment and if there's one which is
less unlikely than all the others but
can still occur that may be it when we
see and so there's some pretty to gulity
about those kind of rare events right
even if they're extremely rare and
there's a simple situations at least in
which one can I can understand some
mention that whether you can understand
in any big picture complicated
situations I have no idea another
important thing that's come up is sort
of the nature of the selection and a
very crucial thing here actually
beginning it is this combination I wrote
down the total number of evolution
experiments are carried out is that the
right number or is it some other
combinations of times and population
sizes does it depend hugely on how I
structure my population is it a
well-mixed population or are they
competing in some more subtle way
particularly warrants and talk he
emphasized things you can get a lot more
diversity in a population I think
everyone will agree that diversity is
crucial you're gonna get more people
more diversity of the population and
avoid things which are pretty good but
not that good
to take over if you do the selection
differently if you have things mix them
so an obvious way that happened is
facial structure in the real world and
whether the competitions local or global
healthy mix back together and so on and
there were numerous range of time scales
that come in even - even - that they're
a much more important important one
which I'm not even putting a question
mark after this a nice thing this is
absolutely crucial is time dependent
environments there is not a fixed set of
things that could be undone fix Fitness
it's changing in time
it's changing multiple time scales and
this wasn't talked about and the crystal
talked about some of these things as
well yesterday and that's really crucial
if one understands things in fixed
things are easy in a fixed environment
it's great I'm going to worry about
those but there are certainly a lot of
things that can happen when I have time
to been in environments but may not be
able to happen fix one and I think for
understanding anything to do with
reality that's absolutely absolutely
crucial one specific context in which
the creation and maintenance of
diversity and came up with in the
immunology immunology the context in a
couple of the talks and the nice thing
about you know in ology is even though
it's awfully complicated it's very small
bits of DNA that it depends on boats in
the case of the virus and in the case of
the of our immune immune system and so
it's long one can hope to make progress
on those are really fast so who wants to
get quantitative understand so another
thing in this red piece of I mentioned
you know once one starts saying we don't
know what that combination parameters
are we really have to talk about
different regimes and we can ask in
specific contexts at least how long the
time to evolve something is does it go
with one over population size as would
be suggested from this combination here
or want to square them in your wife's
will get an example of that and in women
just talk then the does it go is the
number of alleles you're trying to get
here's K or square root of that when
that makes also makes a big difference
right these are these are numbers and
which ones occur make a big a big
difference and one we like on this n
regimes you know what works in different
different regimes and any of these
results have some amounts of revolutions
of universality to them do they apply in
combat other than the Pacific model you
calculate it with right and that's
always the Bugaboo here you do some
mortal you leave out almost everything
and the questions have you captured the
essence of something and so you have
some hope of generalizing it and Lisa's
the kinds of behaviors right and so you
can try to extrapolate things like that
so evolvability
paradox um I think is probably enough
discussion of this that maybe don't need
this but I would like to show this in a
talk with but for the citizen some
others because of the there is is in
something paradoxical
so I have some measured property here
and I'm majoring this is a function of
time okay but I'm going to tell you
which way time is now if you're a
physicist you will look at this and say
okay I'm coming down into some valley
I'm going approaching that and then I'm
fluctuating around a gun like this
obviously times this direction if you
were evolution biologist you say I'm
climbing other to a fitness maximum and
I'm sitting near things like this okay
but I didn't tell you how I did this
plot what I did was I took I do a bar
right here I do a bar there time went
this way time's up and I just waited and
boom first time across here and then I
stopped then I showed you what looks
like it turns out that looks exactly
like the simple context I think what if
I turned it back backwards the typical
so I'm looking at a very rare event but
I move in the rare event that reach some
stressful okay what's that threshold
that's threshold is where that organism
successful enough to get the fossil
record or to have existing organism
descendants now right so where
everything is conditioning upon things
being extremely successful in the future
and anything that does that very
generally will have some aspects to it
this looks at the systematical coming up
the tilma mat you can say what law this
looks as if it's following when it
climbs this hill okay or goes into the
battery if you do next and so you can
say something about it but the
properties of it are really dependent
upon this conditioning upon something
very rare happening okay that's really
crucial when one tries to talk about
things like your mechanism always give
this will upon long-term survival and
that's another thing like it's always
gonna appear as if it has some features
of being a bully
okay this is something where the tiny
scale of fitness is actually crucial
this is on long time scales which
required the thing to actually see in
the context of biology there are various
mechanisms associated with this there
are parents in some sense but of course
real mechanisms are did evolve
okay but they're apparent in that they
evolved for something you could talked
about talked about these the computer
says you say it is a somewhat different
sense of vulnerability we've heard here
but what was focused on is a solution of
one hard problem and don't talk about
the the context of giving a password
okay but you know if you're a virus if
you're a virus you don't have to guess
anything about the immune system of
particular person or even a particular
species all you've got
or speech though the people you could
attack and if you get into one of them
that's fine right there are a lot of you
you can try one of those so they're a
huge number of possible problems and
this is a really crucial part and I
guess came up in ones ones talk of
things are much easier if you've got a
lot of possible problems to solve for
many for many possible solutions in that
case and this came up in sort of a
looser way in several people to mention
again in a minute
but i all defines its own problems to
solve one of the absolute classic things
that comes in all over the place who
tries evolution experiments you try to
select for something but biology chooses
something else okay and that's always
true in there's a nice story about
horrible exams on how you use a
barometer for to mix I have the building
from physics which I won't i won't say
give me the time it's a good analogy
believe me I can someone can ask at the
end of it I could another general thing
which has somewhat come up and I think
rather it's hell much sort of evolved
ability and biology and everything
generally it's associated with sitting
on a borderline okay and I think the
thing is only person I'll quote and he's
alive I don't like pretty dead white
males live ones
the term the edge of chaos I think is
George Kaufman so organismic biology you
know that one fewer good everything's
very modular and everything this this
resistance of that but that is a problem
it's very hard to everything it's
modular how do you get into something
new that's very hard really to change I
love what it's doing I mean this robust
if you elevate the other one you see
these protein connection networks which
are nonsense but those if they look like
random networks and there are some
aspects of actually the functional parts
of the biology but also look sort of
like random networks but of course it
was completely made the network you
can't do it's probably copied rather
thing and so probably in some very loose
sense biology hovers in the middle about
border between these the by the biology
that's been evolutionary successful not
all biology that went extinct a long
time ago another one like that this has
come up he's where the selection is
individual
jeans or selection is on the whole
genome can i really think of selecting
the miss genomes like the night gene or
other another interaction between genes
that I have to think of selecting really
on the whole genome those which is an
asexual straight lexical evolution you
select on the whole genome now but of
course recombination breaks it up
putting back together again so there's a
real suggestion that's sort of natural
and probably in some real sense optimal
is through the organisms and to be on a
borderline between selection on genes
inspection on on on genomes training and
they ever thought about that
recently I think that's a very
interesting general issue another sort
of borderline one it's on timescales
there's time to do do so and things up
during a variation that sort of slow
base for new mutations and the selection
which is relative for us but then really
all these are kernel different time
scales depending on the processes and
this came up anything they want to
understand for probably having these on
the same time scale these some of the
time is probably important that's
another one maybe sit on the borderline
between two different things in the
point of view of the complexity and the
reason why I put on this example is on
might they given the borderline between
having so many tasks you could possibly
do but none of more much interest and
not being able to the other thing there
is a borderline where you can do little
lot but you can do some of them weren't
you're sort of interesting and if one
side of that either the look squared I
love yeah I love you too look squared
yeah that's really fast right and that
comes up there's a context ex-boss the
challah check where that comes up those
either the Bob squared kind of things
but if you then also to the borderline
between here you might oh come on the
borderline between a polynomial an
exponential regime and there's some kind
of behavior in the marginal behavior
there
I believe that's habit that happens in
random cases in at least some of case at
on the borderline right on the
borderline is Italy seems that the
algorithms are something which are
between polynomial exponential but I'm
sure someone cover can correct me on
that correct me on that for random cases
if you're someone on the borderline who
comes out there go to context and of
course the evolution doesn't
laughs one way or other but if you're
not one way the other battle its lineage
about and so your conditioning upon in
this case loosely speaking only one
parameter which is that the things you
see very long-term survival sort of stay
around on this borderline and that's a
sort of loose one-time intersection
verbal ability so one thing I just want
to say is career away from the general
to these sort of specific models and
this is something which I was a
physicist went into often work on
specific models and then you try to
scratch your head and say wait is there
something about this marvelous general
can I go beyond that I want to solve it
not exactly but by the Rasim products
and understand so one good thing I'll
just write prove them but that's me
right or wrong and then what tries to go
from from there instead of so much
thinking about causes of problems in
beginning right so the physics it's more
like you start with one problem and then
you try to build up and say okay the
sort of class around this which is maybe
easier in some ways than just about okay
so one example this was a prebiotic
order kind of like sense like a steel
talked about and we didn't really talk
about how you make different scales of
hinted I'm in there it's a toy model but
it's something because it has a smell of
it of something like actual biology and
then there's morphological development
that there did you talked about it which
also has a smell of biology with a much
further stage along a morphological
development and then there's lots of toy
models that the person talked about
which are fascinating and I think one is
really like you'd be able to learn a lot
from but there's still more the
character of toy model or not trying to
put too much biology in them but if then
one can't explore as much around but
they sort of have some bits of them I
think I think Francis Crick call these
what's
calls them just so mortals have you make
up a story for something but this is not
done and you're just in words but it's
really done with moral and there's a
huge amount one can learn from the men
one may ask
realize with actually some of those or
actually closer they're more realistic
things as well now the difficult all of
these is extrapolating if you think
you're doing something connected to
reality to real numbers mean
but once they make things more formal
from some of these I would like to
define some sort of closet problems have
more difficulty right it could be
evolving more complicated patterns in
six years or bigger or it kind of looks
at about the properties in my seal for
various things but I didn't come up
naturally Watson's um but you might want
to find some measure to the size of the
problem I can call my ko a little n but
then I have to report immediately saying
what are the number of possible problems
that could be solved to do well why
there isn't just be one problem about
four there are many and that was already
explicit in I think all of these three
examples that we we heard about Buddy
mentioned the one with the virus right
as many possible many possible hosts
even something simple as a simple as a
virus and then one would like to get you
know the computer science question about
how difficult is that that difficult to
do this is a function of K and if one
finds is either the K okay too much if
it's some borderline case then maybe one
still can but that one should be
moderately I'm surprised and then of
course it's gonna depend upon the nature
of the competition the recombination
processes and and so on so would like to
get sort of concrete results um
so it's not a good thing for solving any
one of them but if I have many heart
problems and all I need to do is solve
one of them right doesn't matter which
one I thought I thought one of them so
if it's exponentially harder of anyone
but they're exponentially many cuz I'd
better find if I solve those then at
least my equal of Exponential's can
balance each other and it can become
easy can obviously that's a fairly new
statement and there are classes of
things that one can talk about and try
to make make sense of it and I think
that maybe are some natural classes that
might come from some of these or from
some simpler simpler models and a
particular sort of individual works and
one of his of having different patterns
well you can start going with there many
more patterns which I can do well by
getting something like those so
developing to remember you know ten
patterns be very hard but if it's any
ten of a million you know ready that
might be somewhat less hard right but
those kind of things are really
important one two again and then of
course one would like to go back and ask
about questions about any kind of
universality is there anything that one
is learning which is moodle's which in
the limit of some of the numbers being
large lights and lots of large lots of
small numbers that's the kind of regime
for universality them can often hold
central limit theorem being that the
most famous example is there some kind
of causality in these in these large and
large number of limits of something one
can say beyond the very specific I just
wanted to end on one note of actually
coupling to an experimentally observable
statement what experimental but observed
in genomic history and that's a question
of do we have some examples of where
there seems to be some sort of
well-defined limit to complex okay and I
don't know this this is one that seems
at least one is useful to think about
particularly if one is thinking that one
of the things we look at is gene
regulation and trying to understand gene
regulation and bacteria are very simple
simple here they have a conveniently a
factor of a hundred range of genome
sizes so you can ask somehow how things
care with genome sizes the smallest ones
are essentially no transcription factors
at all they don't do gene regulation the
proteins do everything okay
the largest ones have a lot of gene
regulation and there's a very strong hit
trend
is not just some r-value this is a clock
which I should have pulled out of the
with Vermont will stand around it that
the number of transition factors goes of
the square on the sides of the genome
okay and if you talk to you numbers
you're really by the time you get to the
biggest genomes of somewhat more than
ten to the seven the number of spins in
fact is so large there came to be a
substantial fraction a genome and it
seems if you want to regulate anything
that can do more things more chemistry
typically than the back day that we have
and a bacteria that was ten times as big
you wouldn't need more transcription
factors you have ruined the genome so
some of this kind of architecture of how
the bacteria do things seem to have some
intrinsic limit to it
eukaryotes it do it differently the
major difference in how they do it and
it's a random comment or combinatoric
method and i think understanding how
that might have evolved is one of the
most interesting directions so typically
if you've bacteria get more complex
bigger genomes they do more various
things but not by very much they
typically do much more metabolism they
can eat more different things that can
make more different things they can do
other stuff like that
and so you have to kind of regulate all
these metabolic things regulate the
conditions under which you can live so
you're still happy in those and so on
and so somehow what you need to do gets
more complex as well and the empirically
the number 250 factors grows
quadratically and so your bases run out
of steam and even microbial eukaryotes
similar sized genomes they do it
differently and that grows much more
slowly with genome size the amount of
transcription so it's just a curable
thinking something one might say okay
this is route somehow some limit okay
well